[Music]
surprise surprise you guys asked for new
defenders they start dropping some more
promos so let's break this down you may
have spotted some of the Easter eggs in
the backgrounds of these but I tried to
pick all of them out Sigourney Weaver's
character even shows up during one of
the iron fist ones there's a new round
of the Marvel giveaway going on now -
it's for guardians tickets all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video I'm actually
surprised they're posting this stuff so
early but maybe they just want to
capitalize on the trailer coming out and
people going so crazy about it but what
these are just teasing the points of
crossover that we'll see during the
defenders series just through a certain
progression is they each pop up in other
really big locations from the other
characters series the first one is
daredevil showing up in the ran
enterprises building on the 13th floor
if you don't remember the 13th floor of
the building is where Danny ran tailed
Madame Gao when she was conducting her
drug business learning about the big
Empire so that was really only when he
first learned about it he didn't
directly confront her till much later
but he confronted her secretary like
what the hell is going on here what are
you using my family's business for and
then the picture over here on the side
it's kind of dark but it's Harold
Meacham and Danny rands father just
shaking hands just because they're the
ones that started the company so there's
a lot of Danny rands origin story that's
tied up in the way they got rid of his
father made his plane go down that
they'll follow up on an Iron Fist season
to whenever that drops I know there's a
lot of controversy surrounding the
series but I only think the stuff from
that that they're going to address
through the defenders and the daredevil
character is just the drug business that
Madame Gao was conducting like all the
shady stuff that was happening on that
13th floor the next one if you couldn't
tell is Luke Cage showing up in fog
Welles gym there was a scene in Luke
Cage where he was next to a boxing ring
but that was a completely different
place up in Harlem Bogg Welch gym is in
Hell's Kitchen you see the newspaper
clippings on the background from Matt's
father's fight Creole versus Murdock
most of the fighting from Luke Cage that
we've seen in the trailer so far is with
iron fist they're just teasing a little
bit of Heroes for Hire rocky start but
with any luck we'll get to see daredevil
try to throw down with Luke Cage if he
gets his hands on him he'd be done so
he'd have to find some way to get him
inside the mouth he totally ate a
shotgun blast to the head and it just
disabled him for a little while so I
don't think there's
be a whole lot of daredevil versus Luke
Cage the next one is Jessica Jones
showing up at rant enterprises the
newspaper that she's reading just reads
wrong side of the tracks so just a bit
of a hat tip that she's like in this
upper scale world she's from the other
side of the railroad tracks but if you
remember joy Meacham actually hired her
to investigate one of the other board
members sleeping with another woman that
wasn't his wife to get information to
try and influence the way he voted on
their big decisions so there actually
has been some alight Jessica Jones iron
fist crossover even though she herself
never showed up during the series it's
always funny to watch the first episode
in that intro where she talks about how
she earns her living catching people
boning in the dark
this next Iron Fist one is pretty
self-explanatory to Danny Rand just
coming to Jessica Jones to get help with
some investigation now there's a number
of things that he could get help with
but most of his investigating is into
what the hand is doing and following
around Madame Gao because she's still
alive causing trouble at the end of the
Iron Fist series it's implied she'll be
a much bigger thing in the next series
whatever joy Meacham is going to be
doing with the steel serpent so that is
why he's shown up on her door here it'll
be fun to see how she reacts to him she
is a pretty short temper in that trailer
so it seems like she's just making him
sit out there and wait just because she
can't stand the sight of him his next
daredevil one is fun too where he starts
to run into Jessica Jones characters if
you couldn't tell this is Trish Walker
on the bench behind here the Trish talk
radio show is a way for the Jessica
Jones stuff to reach all of the
different series because you pick up
that radio station at Harlem you'd hear
it in Midtown so anywhere any of the
defenders were they'd be able to hear
what was going on we know from the
trailer that daredevil comes in to
represent Jessica Jones because misty
Nights arrested her for busting up a
crime scene that might be somewhere in
Harlem because that's where most of
misty Nights beat is so it sounds like
there's some Jessica Jones Luke Cage
crossover and then daredevil gets
involved maybe when he hears about it
from someone else this implies he either
learns about the Jessica Jones stuff
through the radio show or from jeryn
hogarth because jeryn hogarth is kind of
like jessica jones professional friend
you can't really call them good friends
but they do have a really good working
relationship so it sounds like she might
be passing off a lot of the legal work
to daredevil this might have something
to do with
misty night arrest but the barbershop
looks like it's been reconstructed as of
the end of Luke Cage it was still in
shambles and they were slowly rebuilding
it it was just implied that they were
gonna reopen it eventually but it is a
little confusing because you see Luke
Cage just drive by it in that bus during
the trailer so maybe he's just hesitant
to go back just because of all the
memories but it just implies that for
some reason she's either gonna try and
look Luke Cage up or some investigation
that she's doing for someone else brings
her to the barber shop this is fun
Josie's bar is one of my favorite dive
bars in the Marvel Universe this is
obviously just implies that Luke Cage is
gonna come looking for daredevil and
foggy here but maybe it's because of
some legal help we don't know how he
gets out of sigue prison but in the
trailer he's already out so presumably
that happens pretty quickly in the first
episode or two but they were really
ambiguous about what was gonna happen at
the end of that first season Luke Cage
look it's like okay we're taking you
back to prison because you lied about
your identity maybe somebody in the
Marvel Netflix Universe knows a good
lawyer between jeryn hogarth and matt
murdock and this is fun just watching
Iron Fist show up at Harlem's paradise
if you remember at the end of Luke Cage
it's now controlled by Mariah Dillard in
shades who's kind of like her new
second-in-command ever cottonmouth died
I know everybody wants to bring him back
but the shades character just confirmed
that he was coming back for Luke Cage
season two so they were really vague
about what was going to happen with
Mariah Dillard she just took over the
business at the end of the season she
might also take over his drug business
all the other criminal enterprises he
was involved in there was the weapons
smuggling that was going on with a
Diamondback character really was all
about racketeering money laundering so
maybe there's some crossover with her
drug business in madam GAO's drug
business that'd be the only real reason
for iron fists to go try and investigate
there if you look over here though when
this window comes down at Sigourney
Weaver peeking out from this Escalade
here and you see that Danny Rand wanted
poster too so it looks like he gets
himself into more trouble with Rand
enterprises he's one of those characters
that has a really hard time flying under
the radar so it just makes sense that if
daredevil is gonna cover his face to
hide his identity
wouldn't Danny Rand do the same thing
too so let's all hold our breath in hope
that Danny Rand gets the idea from
daredevil to start covering his face
like the classic comic book style but
like they tease that there
villain connections obviously Sigourney
Weaver meeting with Mariah Dillard is a
very literal connection well let me know
what you guys think about all this I
love the way they're teasing them
crossing over based on their own
investigations they kind of play that
out of the trailer too with Iron Fist
and Luke Cage Claire temple has to like
slap them both in the face look you're
both friends you're on the same side
there's always your traditional hero on
villain action but then you always have
some sort of mystery runner during the
season we're Daredevils trying to learn
about the secret of the kingpin over the
course of season one Iron Fist is trying
to learn about the secret of Madame Gao
and what's going on inside his business
so it just sounds like the larger
mystery about how all these villains
from the different series are connected
is going to bring all these characters
together in the first couple of episodes
there's only eight episodes so I'm
assuming at least by episode 2 episode 3
most of them will have met each other
otherwise it's gonna be a really slow
paced season but let me know in the
comments how quickly do you think it's
gonna be before they all four meet on
screen do you think it'll happen before
episode 4 I feel like it has to happen
before the middle of the season even if
they don't fight together till a little
bit later but just remember the way they
drew the kingpin out during the first
season of daredevil you didn't meet him
right away you heard about his name I'm
expecting the same treatment for
Sigourney Weaver's character where you
hear about her you hear about this
mysterious figure at the top maybe you
hear her voice like her voice was the
voice of the elevator in that first
viral promo they released
[Music]
then a couple episodes later boom you
see the kingpin full-on so maybe the
same thing will happen with Sigourney
Weaver's character but what's gonna
happen next is I've seen new thor
ragnarok new guardians 3 and they just
confirm who some of the big villains are
gonna be on next season of the flash and
arrow so I'll try to get those out as
fast as possible but congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Quincy Tyrell
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round in
this video I'll just announced the
winner the next time I post a Marvel
video while you wait for that you can
click here for a brand new spider-man
trailer and you can click here to
re-watch that defenders trailer thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight